[Music]
please under my love and I can't wait to
see him et spoke to the stars of Captain
Marvel brie Larson and samuel l.jackson
within just hours of each other on
Sunday and each actor gave us a little
taste of what we can expect from Captain
Marvel of course we've seen the success
of Wonder Woman in the DC Universe did
that make you more excited about it do
you feel more pressure or less pressure
I feel pressure in that it's a it's a
character that people love and are
inspired by and I see that and so I want
to do right by that and I want people to
feel like their character is honored but
from the like female standpoint I don't
understand why there's like pressure put
on women as if it's like the most like
shocking concept ever that a woman can
open a movie is like it's kind of a
tired concept like you've proved it all
the time so I don't feel pressure in
that way at all it has been confirmed
and we just spoke to brie that you will
be in the Captain Marvel films very
excited oh okay because it's in the
nineties yeah so what are you most
excited about doing that film and
playing neck with he's like awesome
reason that girl yes she said hello from
London and she's looking forward to
seeing you first up though you can see
both in theaters on other projects
Brie's got the glass castle with Woody
Harrelson honestly tell me did you happy
right yes
and Samuel stars in the hit man's
bodyguard with Ryan Reynolds we're late
what happens in a seatbelt rule
[Music]
you